[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin les enfants aux forums sauf que je
suis content à toi
et pourquoi north mes deux petits amis
sont sages ce soir ils ne font pas de
bruit
ils sont sûrement en train de travailler
ce cher petit jeter son lait voir mon
échelle ou coup je peux entrer bizarre
oui qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est-ce que vous cachez vous rangez
petit coquin vous fouillez dans le sac
de votre maman oui non m
oui
oh vous savez que ce n'est pas bien ce
que vous faites
il ne faut pas ou peu de choses une
houppette qu'elle sent bon ne soyez pas
indiscret les enfants eu ça qu'est ce
que c'est c'est pour faire du feu c'est
un briquet nikaïa que de bouchra huawei
après sa maman induction tu le perds mes
mots forts elle mange des bonbons votre
âme au nord comme ça voilà ce sont des
clés soit c'est sans nenê avait été de
foot et les enfants c'est très vilain
jeu voulu ni à l'eau remettait tout dans
le saint affrique
moi je mets ans une fleur dans le chat
de maman et je dirais que je lé bien
rangée et moi et je dirais que j'aidais
nicolas singer son sac et moi personne
ne fait rien on lui dira que c'est toi
qui a fouillé dans le sac les polissons
que ce qu'elle va penser de moi c'est
pas beau
[Musique]
tokyo panneaux quelques aime bien maman
sevrin leur maman là c'est un leurre
bonne nuit lezons feront de nuit de
noces à demain
[Musique]
allez vite vous couchez les petits et
surtout ne faites pas comme nounours
nicolas et pimprenelle c'est très vilain
de fouiller dans le sac de sa maman
n'est ce pas nounours
nous avons fait de rougemont trop oliva
allons en route gros curieux ont route
bonne nuit les enfants peuvent de boer
eux
[Musique]
oh